[Music]
who can guess what this graph is
depicting alright I'll just tell you
it's a chart showing the attention of
college students during a 50 minute
lecture so as you'll notice most
students lose focus after about 10
minutes and at 40 minutes it spikes back
up just a little bit and the leading
theory is that the professor says
something like in summary or in
conclusion which sparks students
interests and makes them listen and
those transition words are called
attention reset buttons today in the age
of ever shortening attention spans it's
even more important to know about these
buttons and have them in your toolkit so
we're gonna tell you about 4 of them the
first question you might ask is how
often do I need to hit one of these
reset buttons and a general rule of
thumb is about 10 minutes however you do
need to keep in mind your audience if
it's in the morning and you know your
audience is intrinsically very
interested in the topic you're given you
can link them at to about 15 minutes but
if it's right after lunch
it's a beautiful day outside and you
know your students didn't get much sleep
the night before you might want to
shorten it to five and a word of warning
before we dive into the four topics you
need to use a variety of these funds you
can't just choose one and let it be your
favorite people become immune to your
tricks and they become less and less
effective each time your attention graph
look like this so first button tell a
story or a joke we all know that we're
intrinsically wired to enjoy stories as
soon as someone says let me tell you
about a time when this happened to me
even the sleepiest obvious audience
member will start listening
alternatively you can tell a joke we
live in a world of FOMO and if everyone
else in the room begins laughing you're
gonna want to know what the what
everyone's laughing at and start paying
closer attention so we did prepare a
couple example jokes for you guys
so what lies at the bottom of the ocean
and shakes a lot a nervous wreck thanks
guys and what does a nosey pepper do it
gets jalapeno business yeah so you don't
want to use those exact jokes but I
think you guys all get me okay so that's
that good way to hit this reset button
is to really get your audience involved
so before I move on to the specific
let's just take a quick point here
everyone grab your phone and just type
in this on displayed
yeah we did my good it doesn't create
the lingo back so never about that's
right that's right
okay
very similar we have pretty even answers
in here but I will seems to really
appreciate the opportunities to practice
on public speaking in general
so I begun to really think about this
method because I lost quarter I have am
classes every morning and then it was
really really difficult for me to stay
away or pay attention during the lecture
but in my ethics class which was also an
A&M session my professor always asked
students to take a pull of this very
controversial topic of topics like what
do you think about the incest or what do
you think about like eating a dog in
nama view in the morning and then in
always I help me wake up and then we
engage in the lecture so from my
experience this is a highly effective
methodology on other things that you
guys can try is you can make the
audience move around the room if they
look very sleepy or very up not
energized or you can make them stretch a
little bit or you can even make audience
pair off into two or three different
groups of like small size two or three
people and discuss about the topics that
you're presenting so getting your
audience involved it's always more
interactive and fun way compared to you
just speak to the audience one way it
has a live element to it which is going
to hook their audience and then give
your presentation more energy
in there made you all look up to me and
be attention we pay attention to change
you probably aren't aware of the air
condition which is humming in the
background in this room right now
but when it stops you will notice it the
second way to change things up a little
bit in your presentation is to use a
different form of visual aid instead of
using a regular PowerPoint slide I can
choose to use a whiteboard or a flip
chart to come to the same point like
this one which talks about how best to
structure your presentation by using
effective audience free engagement
techniques at every 10 minute interval
ordiance the reset button at all it
effectively to change things up a little
bit is to actually change your voice I
can stand here all day long in my
excitement with no matter how
interesting or animated my voices you
will get bored of it if you listen to
the same voice for a long period of time
and that's when you can either introduce
an audio or a video clip to infuse new
voice into the room you can even have a
mini question-and-answer session in the
middle of your presentation to engage
the audience or you can have a new
co-presenter finally the last way to
reengage your audience is to make a
transition so I noticed several of you
like Fatima you looked up from your
computer when I said finally so why did
you do that the reason is our brains are
programmed to pay attention to these
changes we understand that there's new
information
that's coming so we make a conscious
effort to re-engage and focus on what
the speaker is saying so these are some
of the common transitions that you can
use in addition moving on in contrast or
on the other hand so in conclusion there
are four ways that you can reengage your
audience the first is to tell a joke or
a story second to get your audience
involved which could be giving them a
pull or getting them to talk to each
other the third is to change it up as
Seuss demonstrated with maybe your voice
or your presentation style and last is
to make a transition these tactics have
never been more important than they are
today because with every presentation
that we give we have to compete with the
ultimate distraction the cellphone Adam
for example could have just gotten a
message from his most recent tinder
match and that is the bar that we have
to compete with so I hope next time
you're giving a presentation you keep
this graph in mind and always remember
the red reset button
[Music]